the number one killer of African
Americans is Diet related diseases so
this food system is so broken it's
hurting us in every single way I'm all
for freedom I want I want this country
to eat what you want but we have
designed a system in which the things
that we tell you not to eat are being
subsidized and the things we tell you to
eat we don't subsidize at all so when my
kids walk into a bodega in Newark they
can get a twinkie-like product cheaper
than an apple because we as a society
have said we're going to subsidize
everything in that twinkie-like product
and not the apple and everybody on this
along the chain is getting hurt we as a
society no matter your right or left we
need to begin to expand Consciousness
that this system is by Design producing
the results that we're seeing and we can
just redesign it so farmers Thrive and
consumers thrive in health and see what
ways we can make improvements on it to
begin to show people there's a better
way